one of the characters in Milton Morales
novel is considered blank because he
deliberately defies an oppressive
hierarchical society so we could think
about what word with you would be
considered blank if you're deliberately
defying an oppressive hierarchical
society so let's think about it so the
first choice is rebellious well this
just seems pretty good rebellious if
your rebellious that means that you're
rebelling against something that you
tend to rebel to rebel means that you're
you're kind of fighting the power you
are rising up against against the man
you are you are you are deliberately
defying an oppressive hierarchical
society so this seems to be a pretty
good fit one of the characters in Milton
Murray Yama's novel is considered
rebellious because he rebels against an
oppressive hierarchical society he
deliberately defies an oppressive
hierarchical society you could literally
you could literally replace the word he
deliberately you could replace the word
defies with the word rebel and it would
make complete sense because he
deliberately rebels rebels against I
guess i should say rebels against an
oppressive hierarchical society so
someone who defies or rebels against
well their their rebellious but we could
look at these other choices to just make
sure that they don't also fit in some
way so here they're saying so choice B
would be one of the characters in in
Milton moriyama novel is considered
impulsive well impulsive just means that
you kind of you don't think before you
act you kind of just do something you
could be impulsive in a lot of different
ways it could be in some ways rebelling
but it could be impulsive just just you
know just think not acting before you're
thinking so this doesn't seem as as
close to deliberately defying an
oppressive hierarchical society artistic
well that doesn't really you know that's
not even you know deliberately defying
an oppressive hierarchical society
sometimes artists have done things like
that but rebelling or being rebellious
is much closer to this than you know
just being artistic you could be
artistic and you know I have nothing to
do with rebelled of defying and
oppressed
hierarchical society you just want to
kind of go into a field and work on your
art industrious well industrious means
you're you're kind of very you're always
busy doing things your productive your
you're working hard and someone who's
rebellious might be industrious in their
rebellion but it doesn't mean that
you're deliberately defying an
oppressive hierarchical society so if
anything you could be very industrious
being part of the oppressive
hierarchical society you're being you're
busy and oppressing people okay so so
little rule will rule that out and then
it's considered tyrannical because he
deliberately defies an oppressive
hierarchical society so tyrannical you
see that you see the kind of the root of
tyrant right over there so that's really
you're being like a you're being like a
tyrant and so someone who's rebelling
against or who is defying an oppressive
hierarchical society that's kind of the
the opposite of a tyrant a tyrant to
someone who would kind of run the
oppressive hierarchical society so I
would rule that one out as well so you
can feel even better but if I was doing
this under time pressure I got to
rebellious that feels right you're
rebelling against against the the
hierarchical society I would just go
with that and and move on and if you
have some extra time you could come back
and review these other choices